and here we are okay so
uh welcome to the session uh this is
part of
our speaker's mentorship program um
we are essentially trying to support our
speakers especially new speakers so this
presentation
has been designed for people who are new
to
giving tech presentations it's going to
be a bit of a meta presentation
uh presentation about how to give a
presentation and
we're going to have time for your
questions as well
my name is marco i'm a chair organizer
of payday to london
i've been chairing our local conference
for a few years and now
with paid data global i'm the speaker
support chair so
i'm involved in all the activities
regarding the
support for for our speakers on the left
you have a picture of me in my better
days
and on the right there's a picture of
pamela who is also
been working with me um with the
speaker's mentorship program
uh she's from the python chile user
group
uh so she's covering essentially other
time zones
with with this presentation and we've
been working together
to prepare the material on the caller i
also have a chaitana from
pedeita delhi who is helping me today
with the with the questions moderating
the chat
you want to say hi chaitan or are we
good
yeah uh hi everyone so i'm from parity
to delhi as
marcos said uh i'm from india obviously
and i'll be
representing here india section so i see
a lot of speakers from india here
so if you have any questions as marco
said you can post it in the chat i'll be
keeping an eye over there or you can uh
mute yourself and ask
when marco gives you the time thank you
all right thanks so um
the two main pillars of the presentation
here
are essentially how to design our
presentation
and how to deliver our presentation
these are the two main parts
um you see three bullet points on the
on the outline here because before we
get into that i also
want to mention that it's useful to
start kind of sketching your
presentations so things that you
would like to do before you start even
uh designing your
your material so these are the topics
that we're going to touch on
uh today starting from the
beginning sketching our presentation
actually before we start
it's good to sort of pause for a moment
and
think about where you are okay so if
you're here
it's because you have sent a proposal
for our conference the proposals
all the proposals uh have been through a
review process
we had more than 100 reviewers uh
looking after
i think 350 or so proposals i don't
remember the exact numbers
uh many many proposals and many good
proposals anyway
and if you're here it means that some
reviewers and then
our by data committee uh let's consider
your work
valuable for our audience okay so there
is a group of
highly skilled uh professionals in the
data science space that
think your work is uh interesting
valuable
worth presenting at the conference this
is something you should consider because
often
especially first-time speakers feel like
maybe they don't really belong here but
if you're here it's really because you
deserve it
so think about that for a moment before
you you even start
pi data global uh is uh is going to be
one of the most prestigious data science
conferences in the war we have
representatives from pedita london by
the berlin amsterdam
new york los angeles chicago
daily and so many more that
i'm going to forget now but we have
roughly 150 groups by data groups around
the world
and we have a very solid representation
so we're happy to have you here
and yeah take a moment to to kind of
congratulate yourself
for being here and think about where you
are and after you
uh you realize where you are uh it's
good to think about where you want to go
so what's your goal with this
presentation
what's the purpose of your presentation
what what do you want to say
at our conference so typically your
proposal
already has a bit of an outline of what
you're going to talk about
okay and you might have already some
kind of bullet
points that you want to touch on you
might have either uh
take away messages or any way a rough
idea of
what is going on with your presentation
still you know think about
the presentation itself now so are you
going to talk about
maybe some open source library that
you've been working on
or that that you have been altering or
are you going to present some kind of
academic
research some results that you want to
deliver that you want to propose at the
conference
uh just some knowledge that you want to
share that you acquire recently
so uh thinking about your direction here
is always
useful before you even get into
preparing the presentation
and the key question i would say is uh
who are you talking to right who is your
audience
who are you uh preparing and delivering
this this presentation for
so focusing on the audience it's going
to be very very
helpful for you to clarify to to kind of
fix
all your ideas in your mind and to
understand
what you want to talk about so who's the
audience what is their background
why should they care about your content
how is your presentation going to be
relevant
or useful or important or interesting
for them
okay um i've delivered many many
presentations
at by data events app icons i've been
teaching for uh for 20 years
and when i started thinking about my
audience a bit more
that's when the the shift happened for
me and
that's when my presentation started
really uh becoming a little bit better
so thinking about your audience is
crucial for your success at the end of
the day you you need to care about your
audience
and if you don't have an idea just yet
about your audience
often especially for people who give a
talk for the first time
your audience could be yourself two
years ago or yourself five years ago
so what what would you like to tell to
your younger self what did you learn
that you wished you learned a few years
ago that's often one way to think about
it but there is no no hard rule
uh still keep your audience always in
mind and at this point you start you
start
sketching your presentation a bit more
we're talking about high level structure
here so
it could be really bullet points or
boxes and arrows where you literally on
paper
start sketching your presentation
doesn't have to be on paper you can
start
working on your slides if you prefer you
can
open up your favorite presentation
software
powerpoint or keynote or whatever you
prefer
but i suggest you to start really from
the from the outline from the uh
kind of looking at things from a
distance now if you have no idea about
the overall outline of your presentation
a starting point is typically something
that looks like this
so more or less every tech presentation
is going to have a central problem
so you start with an introduction to the
problem a problem statement or an
introduction to the broader topic if you
prefer
from there you would like to discuss the
algorithm algorithmic approaches the
tools the libraries
all you know the solution that you adopt
to tackle the problem and
finally you get to your results or the
lessons that you have learned
along the way rough outline
is not always so linear there is no hard
requirement
but typically in a tech presentation we
have this kind of structure so you can
start from there
clarify what your problem is clarify how
you solve it and clarify
what you learn along the way it's a good
starting point
and then you're going to iterate
probably a little bit on the
on the outline per se if you don't know
anything else
it's a good way to start now uh
now that you have your outline a bit
more clear in your mind you can start
thinking about designing
uh your presentation designing the
support material for your presentation
i'm talking about support material
meaning
slides and jupiter notebooks
code whatever makes sense for you
a common mistake that people often do
especially when they're new to
speaking is this kind of misconception
about the u.s lights being
your presentation well your presentation
is not really about your slides your
presentation
is the message the story that you want
to tell the message that you want to
deliver
your slides are simply there as a
supporter slice should support the
message but the slice should not be your
message
okay so that's something to uh to keep
in mind
so once you have this in mind you start
designing your slides and
you will end up with something that
looks like this so
you design your slides because you think
slides are going to be useful to support
your presentation
but probably you're going to overdo it
and you will write a lot of slides
and you have a lot to say many many
words because
you know there's a lot that you want to
say and not enough space on the slides
so you're going to cram all the content
into slides
and you're going to use a tiny font
because you want to put a lot of stuff
on the slide
and you don't really realize it that is
too tiny because
you know it's in front of you and you
can read it anyway
and then when you deliver your
presentation you will end up reading
your slides word by word
but the people can read faster than you
so they will get tired
so with this one i've done essentially
two i committed two
capital scenes that people often do
one was kind of reading my slides
if i sit through your presentation
i don't want to listen to you reading
your slides i want to listen to your
message i can read the slides by myself
so tell me your message tell me your
story that's the the main suggestion
and the other uh problem is a design
problem uh
just too much in a single slide so a
common mistake is
overloading your slides and the
suggestion is don't
don't overload your slides don't put too
much content on your slide
okay again the slides are there
as a supporter you want people to focus
on your
voice and your message you don't want
people to
kind of spend all their mental energy
reading your slides okay so just a
simple sentence or a simple phrase or
maybe
images they can be useful to capture
people attention
while you are delivering your story so
looking at our previous uh slide that is
very very dense to match content
how can we improve it basically what i
just told you about not putting too much
on slider
and the whole story that is written on
this very dense slide could be
really uh simplified summarized even
very much i'm telling you that slides
are useful but you shouldn't put too
much you shouldn't overdo it
so typically you can get rid of a lot of
text
and now this slide has the same amount
of information
roughly as the previous one without all
the noise
so first step summarize your content
it's okay
if you start uh doing a bit of a brain
dump on your slide and you've write a
lot
but then the suggestion is to start
summarizing summarize your text
you condense this kind of long message
into something more digestible and it
also helps you to
think about your message to think about
what you want to say really
remember your slides are not lecture
notes just a visual aid
that you use to support your message
from there we can take it a step further
we can
for example here get rid of the bullet
points um
bullet points in general can be useful
in context if you're
showcasing a bullet list but here they
they're not particularly meaningful
i'm getting rid of the bullet points uh
in general i would say any graphical
component that
doesn't really serve a purpose uh could
be distracting
so you want to remove everything that
could just distract people okay so the
the next step after you summarize is a
simplify the design
okay so simplification will be the the
main keyword here
any graphical gimmick should go if it
doesn't serve
a particular purpose if you do power
points
uh you know the transitions between
slides they were fun
back in the 90s now they're just
annoying don't do anything distracting
that's the message
it's okay to have a nice template you
don't have to go black
font on a white background like i'm
doing here
it's okay to make them pretty they just
don't have to be distracting
and if your company has some branding
policies or guidelines maybe there's
only so much you can do it's great that
your company is supporting you
again keep in mind that you want to
showcase your message without
distractions then you kind of iterate
you you go through a few iterations here
you condense your content again you
simplify your presentation
so carry on and simplify more and more
until
you literally distill your message into
something very very simple
and now i've ended up with a small slide
with a tiny piece of text
and a lot of blank space so we can now
maybe think about presenting the message
in a nicer
more appealing more readable way so the
same
same message could go into something
that looks like this so
bigger font which means more readable
also a nicer alignment kind of in the
middle
so it looks a bit better graphical
components
can be useful here icons or emojis
whatever makes sense in context here i'm
saying slides are okay they're useful
they're nice they're good
but don't overdo it so make them easy to
read that's the kind of the short
message and this slide here
it's sort of giving us the same the same
message as the previous uh
cluttered slide okay it's just much more
easy to digest
easy to read and in this way the the
audience will
sort of get the message immediately and
then they will listen to your
voice they will listen to your story
okay so try to compare
the simplified slide with the original
very verbose
bullet points they deliver the same
message without
all the clutter but now what if
you really have a lot to say and you
have a lot that you want to share with
the audience
um why not put in everything on the
slide well my suggestion
for you is to share some kind of speaker
notes
or maybe jupiter notebook whatever makes
sense so if you have
extra content that you really want to
share if you have a lot to say but it
doesn't really fit
in the slides so to speak um put them in
the speaker's notes
share the notes if people want to
get into the details of what you're
saying and they will they will look for
the notes that we reach out
uh you can put a link to the speaker's
notes
at the beginning of your presentation or
you can you can put it
in your in the abstract of your talk so
it will be also available on the
conference website on schedule um
you can share it on social media on the
chat that
we're going to have during the during
the conference so there are several ways
to share your material
you don't have to put everything on your
slides just the key components will
uh will do also for sharing code
um the code that you might share on your
slide doesn't have to be you know
something that you could run on your
slides you're not going to run
your slides you're going to run maybe
something on on a proper python script
or
on a jupiter notebook
so that's what you want to share and on
your slides you just put the key
components
uh the the key ingredients of your story
okay
so that's the main suggestion that's
what i'm doing here i'm not putting
everything i'm telling you here on the
slides uh i'm going to share my notes
and i'm going to share also your
questions and the
uh the relevant answers uh in a few days
okay um now talking about uh
design i want you to sort of pause for a
moment
and think about the usage of images
if they're useful images symbols icons
diagrams plots whatever you call them
they can be useful to
sort of deliver complex messages
probably you heard that a picture is
worth a thousand word
all in all that's true we can describe
complex
concepts using a picture so you capture
the attention of the audience
they don't have to read a lot of stuff
but you're showcasing something complex
at the same time you can even convey
emotions and whatnot
uh based on what you're talking about
and on the picture
um not everything can be represented as
a picture especially if you want to
share a piece of code for example but
that's an option that you should
always keep in mind now the previous
image for example was something to say
well stop for a moment and think about
imaging and i've been using a stop
signal
that is kind of a universal symbol if
you want
well there is a war stop in it so you're
going to stop
and also the the shape and the color of
the signal is something that
you see across many many countries so
you feel like maybe
uh it's a universal symbol uh well i
started
digging a little bit more into it and i
realized that well
while there is some uh kind of uh
understanding of
his top signal across around the world
is not really universal
and it happens more often than we think
often universal symbols
are less universal than we think okay
at pi data global we're going to have a
global audience
okay so different cultures different
people different languages
and the context does matter here so
something that is obvious for us
it's not necessarily going to be obvious
for everybody in the audience so even
though images will be helpful
you can still think about well is this
really going to convey
the message that they want to share with
people
so in summary global audience that's a
good thing
we're going to have a different let me
say cultures as in
different experiences parts of life
a lot of different people coming
together in the same forum and this is
really great
so we should really strive for using
including
inclusive language and inclusive imagery
okay
something that again is obvious for us
maybe it's not going to be obvious for
everybody
and different cultural norms maybe
you know something that is totally fine
in some culture could be upsetting in
other culture
try to think about that as well whenever
possible uh you should try to
be as inclusive as possible in your in
your presentation both for the use of
language and
the images that you choose one more
suggestion when crafting your slides is
the use
the usage of different visual aids
visual aids as in something that you can
use to guide
the audience um to focus on particular
details of
a slide so let's say you have a bigger
diagram and you want the people to focus
on one component
or like i'm doing here there's a bit of
a phrase and i want you to focus on one
particular
word let's say i want you to focus on
the word the visual in this particular
case well i could
literally point to the word visual using
an arrow okay
or you could highlight the word visual
itself in
many different ways or you could blur
everything out
apart from the word visual this is what
happens
you know when we do presentations in
person uh people
sort of point at the big screen they
jump around
typically they end up not talking into
the microphone so it's a bit of a
shamble
[Applause]
so i would say the usage of visual aids
that we have to use in virtual
presentation because we're not there
pointing at the moment
at the monitor is something that is
going to be helpful also for in-person
presentations okay
and again try to make it not
distracting okay something that you
would just want to
use for the audience to
basically benefit from your presentation
for in-person presentations sometimes
you also see laser pointers
being used to kind of point to
particular elements in the
slides and maybe you think
people will take you more seriously if
you have a laser pointer but they they
can be really
distracting so people just waving the
pointer around
it's not going to be useful you're going
to give me a headache if you just wave
your pointer
so i would say using visual aids to walk
people through
what you want to say can really help the
audience to
to kind of stay with you stay engaged
i've been talking about visual aids
and using images um one last
consideration
here um and i'm not really an expert on
accessibility
but something that at this point we
should really consider
you know not everybody in the world is
going to be able to see the number in
the middle of the slide here
uh in particular there's a percentage of
the population
um suffering from color blindness
and they're not going to be able to uh
to get the number that you might see
in in this particular presentation i'm
not an expert on accessibility myself
but what i want to say is just it's
worth thinking about it a little bit
at the very least putting together green
and red
on the same slide close to each other we
kind of know that it's not
necessarily a good idea you may want to
look into
maybe color palettes that are a bit more
uh
friendly for column blindness everything
that i've been telling you so far
big phones and whatnot serves the
purpose of being
easy to use easy to digest for a
broader audience let's say so even
though
i don't have uh you know the
deep knowledge in accessibility uh still
i would like people to have
at least some appreciation that
this is something we should think about
okay in our design
so wrapping up on the design part and
then we're going to pause for a moment
if there is any questions so feel free
to
drop your questions in the chat in the
meanwhile so we've been discussing about
making slides simple easy to digest put
only
what is needed on your slides
readability counts if you
uh if you stick to the pep 20 xenopython
okay
readability counts so use a large font
size
as a rule of thumb if you are looking at
your slides on your
laptop let's say you put it full screen
if you stand a couple of meters away
if you can't read your slides then the
font is too small
when we are going to back to be back to
in-person meetings think about the
person sitting at the end of the room
okay so if you can't read your slides
from a couple of meters away from your
laptop then the person sitting at the
back is not going to be
able to read the uh the slides on the
big screen
that's typically what happens don't put
everything on the slides
share notes share code share everything
that
would otherwise clutter your slides your
audience will
will appreciate that use pictures
whenever possible
they help conveying the message
but also try to be inclusive if you do
so make sure that you use inclusive
imagery inclusive language and try to
use visual aids
whenever possible once again with the
purpose of helping the audience
so that was the first part of the
presentation about design
i'm going to pause for a moment before
getting into the second segment
do we have any question in the chat
chatan
yep we have one from sanam so
sonam is asking that she wants to know
if
sharing a code on the notebook and if
there are two or three notebooks should
i close the ppt and then
switch between the notebook or what what
is preferable according to you
um there is no hard rule here so about
sharing your material and switching
between the presentation and notebook
there's no hard rule
just think about how you can make the
transition
smooth let's say uh don't uh don't
over stress it i would say you can
simply
you know be on your slides and then you
switch screen uh
you know go back to regular view uh from
a
kind of full screen view you go back to
regular view and then you switch into
the
browser where you have the notebook not
a huge
a huge deal if you are comfortable with
editing
video editing i mean um you can think
about editing out
the segment where you are doing the
switch so it will look a bit
smoother but you don't have to do it
okay
don't don't sweat it you can
basically share your screen and do what
you would do in a
in person presentation that's typically
good enough for uh
for the talk even even for a virtual
delivery
if you do have editing skills and you're
happy to use them you're happy to do the
extra work
by all means that would be great but
don't feel like you have to
and just make sure that you have the
link to the notebooks if it's like a
github repo
or whatever you find more useful make
sure that the link
is also included in your slides and all
the references are there
other questions all right
thanks michael for answering this we
have one more from elisha so she's
asking if uh i'm sorry if i
use the wrong pronoun but uh elijah is
asking what are the
key points to add in a slide when you
are introducing yourself as a speaker
the key points to introduce yourself
yeah in the slides yeah
so if the question is you want to craft
a slide
to introduce yourself yeah so what are
the key points
that one should add there is no hard
rule
in whatever you want people to know
about you
it's fine in in my intro slides i didn't
tell you
what i do for a living i just told you
that i'm from perita
london and for the purpose of the
presentation
this is good enough if you have
your employer supporting you typically
people have to say i work as a software
developer for such and such
or on the other side if if your employer
is not supporting you and
they don't want you to share that you
work for them you might want to keep it
private
there's no hard rule i've seen also
presentations where the
speaker was just keeping the intro slide
just getting into the
the content right away there are
different ways of thinking about it
short answer whatever you want to share
with people about you
is going to be fine if you are if you
are a developer if you're a data
scientist
or a researcher whatever the job title
is
where you're from
yep we have one more so this question is
in two parts
and christopher is asking is it okay for
us to do some practice talks at the
local pi data meetups
this is the first part and the second
part goes like or maybe
we can post the video online to get some
feedback
so practice is going to come up in the
second segment
where it talk about delivery of the
presentation
and if you have local meetups that are
happy to have you presenting that's a
good idea because you're going to have
an audience
so by all means if you have the chance
do it
you don't have to do it but if you can
do it it's
it's always good rehearsing in front of
an audience
can be a good idea as well if you have
colleagues or friends that can help you
uh you know kind of sparing a half an
hour or one hour
for you it's also a good idea
when you do this kind of rehearsing in
front of an audience of
friends and family let's say people feel
like they really have to give you
feedback
and they they tend to be kind of overly
polite and whatnot
so maybe the feedback that you get
is not necessarily actionable per se
maybe they just feel like they have to
make a comment
um so um you know don't expect feedback
do the rehearsing just for you to go to
your presentation to understand
the timing to understand how you feel
about presenting and so on
rather than seeking feedback from a
generic
audience then if you're lucky you will
have somebody
pointing out maybe tiny issues with the
presentation with the design of the
slides
with the content random type or whatever
otherwise rehearsing should be more for
you
to kind of understand yourself rather
than seeking for feedback at least from
from my experience it's also good to
you know if your friends telling you
yeah you're doing a good job
it also feels good so that's fine as
well
this is all the questions that we have
okay
one more question yeah please like yep
so i was thinking about
the thing that he was saying when we
were using
like uh graphics or something that we
have to be more inclusive so
yeah i was looking up this that the
thumbs up sign that you used is also
offensive in some countries like iran
and greece so
i'm thinking like how far one should go
while checking out these things that
if this is inclusive or not
it's an excellent question and uh the
the i guess the short answer is that at
some point
we we are going to screw up i guess
in a way or another whether we mean it
or not
so there must be at the very least a
learning process
and and we don't have to make it
we're not the ones who should make a big
deal out of it right you you can just
apologize and move on
um and then it's for the other people to
choose
whether if the whether the apology is is
good enough and it's genuine or or not
i don't have a very very strong answer
here
um and i think we shouldn't overthink it
um we live anyway in in a world that is
getting more and more global so we are
exposed
a bit more than let's say 20 years ago
to a global audience
and we should try to learn from it
that's all i'm i'm suggesting the
um the suggestion about uh
inclusivity um you know when possible
try to avoid jokes on topics that we
know are going to be
something that that make people upset
and they could be
uh divisive and so on otherwise uh
um just go with with your your common
sense so far
i don't have an answer for you know
everything that could potentially upset
people
just try to avoid it consciously if you
can that's the
simple suggestion okay
thank you for your answer yeah of course
so let me go into the second half of the
presentation and then we're going to
have again
uh more time for questions at the end
and this is going to be about the
delivery and the starting point and the
most crucial point for me
is you have to prepare you have to take
the time to prepare
i know that the message often here is a
practice practice practice but i'm using
prepare as a word because when i was a
student i was attending one of these
how to prepare a uh presentations
um and the lady said something like
if you fail to prepare you should
prepare to fail so they were prepared
stuck in my mind and it sounds a bit
dramatic but in my experience there is
some truth here
okay so the success of your delivery
will heavily depend
on how well you prepare there's no hard
rule here
uh you just need to to kind of put the
time
and and take the time to prepare you
should
work on your slides of course but you
should also
rehearse your presentation a few times
until you feel like everything runs
smoothly now with the
online delivery that we are recording
basically if something goes wrong you
can
record again uh but then it means that
you're going to spend more time so
you might as well just uh go go into it
with the mindset that you have to put
the time
and remember that it always takes more
time that you think
okay that's um true still after
doing many many presentations so the
time that i spent here
was much more that than i expected and
that's how it is
as a rule of thumb there is no hard rule
but as a rule of thumb
anything between 10 and 20
hours per hour of delivery so for this
segment
i took roughly two working days for
preparing the material
plus the rehearsing
it could be more it could be less so you
might have already a better idea
than me when you're working on your
presentation you might have
some material from other presentations
from colleagues that you can reuse
diagrams and whatnot still you have to
prepare
the worst thing that could happen during
your presentation is that
you switch to the next slide and you get
surprised by your own slides because you
don't know what to expect
right so if you prepare you kind of know
everything smoothly
you know the flow of your presentation
and then everything will be
fine so preparation is key and
preparation and rehearsing in particular
is fundamental because when people give
a presentation in public for the first
time
they tend to speak much much faster or
much much
slower than they usually do and for you
to know how
fast or or how slow you are in the
live presentation you need to try you
need to
rehearse so rehearsing will help you
basically finding your pace
finding your voice so this is about
finding your pace but also finding how
you say things out loud
how you can sort of merge together
concepts
how everything flows okay how you find
your confidence
and how you want to craft your message
finding your voice is really about you
you don't have
i didn't say this one explicitly but
just to be clear you don't have to
implement
everything i'm telling you here this is
just my suggestion but your
presentations
should be reflecting how you give the
interpretation
so that's what i mean by find your voice
we already have one
uh marco in the pi data global committee
we don't need any more
we need your ideas your voice uh to come
through
okay and the rehearsing is a way to find
uh
those uh ideas find uh that particular
voice
find how the the voice sounds and
finding also how happy you are with your
voice and how it sounds
and as a positive side effect
that you also know about the timing when
you craft your slides maybe you've heard
people saying
one slide per minute well
it's just any approximation here just as
good as any
um we don't really know how long it's
going to take until we go through the
slides
okay so rehearsing will tell you how
long the presentation
will take and when delivering a
presentation at a conference the timing
is not a suggestion the timing is
something you have to stick to it so for
regular talks we have half an hour
30 minutes presentation and for uh
short talks we have five to ten minutes
or anything in between so below ten
minutes for sure talks and
half an hour for regular talks it's okay
if you do it a bit shorter
it's never okay if you do it longer and
this is going to be
particularly true when we go back to
in-person meetings where there is the
next person
who wants to go on stage you cannot
overrun and you cannot take any
any of their time okay so stick to the
timing uh it shows
first of all respect for the audience
and for the next speakers
and it's all about preparing and kind of
being ready to deliver your message
next i want to mention the aspect of
using humor in
your presentation you more or jokes in
general
this can be okay presentations
can be even fun can be entertaining
should be engaging presentations should
be engaging
now the risk here especially when you're
not new to it is that you
are going to overdo it again and
you kind of try very hard to look like a
professional
comedian or stand-up comedian anyway
and in that case the audience will will
notice that you're trying too hard
to to be funny you're delivering a tech
presentation after all so the suggestion
is
you know some humor if it's natural if
it flows
naturally into your presentation it's
going to be fine
um don't push it too hard just for the
sake of trying to look
funny whatever you do
make sure that you're not going to
alienate your audience okay
so jokes we as we mentioned earlier
using inclusive language
also jokes should not be exclusionary
you should never tell a joke that is
going to put off a group of people
any particular we're going to have a
global audience so some kind of humors
that are fine
in some particular country or in some
particular group of people are not going
to be fine
in other groups of people so if you find
yourself in a place where
a catholic priest a rabbi and a data
scientist walk into a bar
um don't go there nothing good is going
to happen there okay
so jokes are fine but remember the code
of conduct
never try to alienate your audience if
you alienate your audience they will
stop listening to your message even if
you're giving
a good presentation otherwise you just
tell you know bad joke
that's enough to put people off and they
will not listen to you
another type of jokes that doesn't
typically go very well is
whenever you try to put yourself down in
a in a sense
often people especially first-time
speakers they have this kind of a
humor as a defense mechanism saying uh
yeah
didn't really have time to prepare this
is not going to be very good
something like that if you tell me the
presentation is not going to be good why
should i sit through your presentation
right
you're going to put a lot of people off
in this way
um just open saying uh i'm happy to be
here
and uh this is what i want to tell you
and
the audience will just sit through your
presentation and listen to you
okay so once again humor is fine um
you know but try to craft it carefully
if it flows well with your presentation
and never try to uh alienate your
audience
now oops uh before we get into uh
the delivery um through recording which
is what we're going to do in
the pi data global conference i just
want to mention a couple of tips that
are
maybe a bit more specific for the for
the recording here
um remember the deliverable for the
conference
is a recording of your of your
presentation
um the the deadline is uh
not written on stone it's kind of a
mid-october
you're going to get a communication from
the technical
committee or from the program committee
uh in a matter of days
with a more clear deadline and
whatnot but we are aiming for
mid-october anyway for the delivery
after the presentation you're going to
attend a couple of live q and a sessions
during the conference so this is going
to be in november
during the conference so people are able
to ask you
questions during your talk or at the end
of your talk and i think you're going to
be
asked to attend two different sessions
to
cater for different time zones
essentially okay
now before we get into the recording
part first of all think about
your environment talking about your room
this is not my room it's just a
picture that i found if your room is
going to be
messy it could be distracting okay so
your room should
be neat enough
for for people not to be distracted
let's say so
in my case you see there's nothing here
not in particular here you don't you
don't have to sell you're not selling
your room your house even
so it doesn't have to be something that
looks good on a brochure
just have to be something neat enough
and neutral enough
so that people don't notice essentially
so tidy up a little bit
ideally uh your environment should also
be
quieter so if you have things like uh
washing machine running downstairs um
probably there's going to be some
background noise coming through your mic
so think about that as well i think
about also what
the fact that you're going to share your
personal space with the with the
audience so if you have
you know your kids running behind you in
your presentation
um there is no problem with that but
think about whether this is something
you want to share with people
okay so here i uh put the camera at an
angle that i'm
okay with there is no uh particular
issue with what i'm sharing
in my background um i'm not sharing kind
of the rest of my
living room and bedroom and whatnot i'm
just sharing this little corner which is
uh
inoffensive enough okay so think about
your environment
as part of the environment think about
the lighting situation
uh this is din from the technical
committee
so on the left you have a bad example of
lighting because you have light coming
from the back
and when the light is coming from the
back it's going to be difficult to see
your figure
and everything will look kind of darker
apart from the window so here i've been
closing the curtains
and i've been switching off the lights
the artificial lights uh
in front of me and what you should
obtain is something that looks like the
picture on the right
where the figure the face the
upper body is clearly visible
you don't have to be a kind of a
professional here something
as simple as closing the curtains and
switching on the lights
typically is going to be enough okay
also think about the camera and the
angle of your camera if you're using a
laptop in particular if you
put the laptop as you would do normally
when you are doing
your work probably the angle is not
going to be flattering
you're going to say kind of up my nose
if i pull the the laptop here
so what i'm doing for this presentation
is i'm putting the
laptop on a little standard if you don't
have a stand for a laptop you can use
books just to raise the level of the
laptop a little bit and make sure that
the angle
of the camera is something you're happy
with okay so
there's no kind of a high-tech solution
here it's just a matter of
positioning your camera as you uh as you
want the people to see you basically
and once you're ready once the room is
uh
you're happy with the layout of the room
once the hardware and software
setup is uh is ready to go this
suggestion is always
try to do a bit of a screen test so do a
short recording of you
talking through your slides something
less than five minutes is good enough
couple of minutes
so you will become a bit more familiar
with the whatever software you're using
and you will see how things move around
so here
as i go full screen things change and
move around if i do it for the first
time maybe i'm surprised but
i've done it already before the session
so i know exactly what is what
and what goes where so those kind of
things just to make sure everything runs
smoothly and
uh making sure that you're happy with
the quality
of the recording with the what you see
and with what what you listen as well i
know
people don't like to listen to themself
but just for the sake of
managing the quality of your
presentation that's something you should
really think of
and uh it's also a good idea for
rehearsing your presentation so if you
record yourself and then you you know
take the
painful effort to watch you uh
through your presentation you can see if
the presentation runs smoothly or if you
can
rephrase something and whatnot okay so
it's always good to
test and do a screen test and i'm
wrapping up on the
delivery part of the presentation here
so in summary
take the time to prepare and as you take
the time to prepare as you rehearse you
will find
your voice you will find your pace make
sure that you understand the timing of
your presentation maybe you need to go
back to designing your presentation cut
something put something in the speaker
notes or
in the additional material and as you're
going through uh
you're giving a text presentation some
humor is fine if it comes naturally if
it flows
and if you're not overdoing it of course
try to be
always as respectful as possible
and as you're delivering think about the
setup of your room
uh there are more details in the
document that you got from the technical
committee uh with a few details about
you know what to do and
how to achieve good results just tips
here there's no
hard rule whatever works for you but we
just want you to think about
the the setup and finally test your
setup with the screen test okay so
that's the
idea for the delivery now um
i'm going to pause again for a moment
just in case there are questions if you
have any questions please
uh drop them in the in the chat and
i'm going to close then the segment
telling you about the
question and answer that comes after
your talk uh but before we get there
uh chetan any question from uh
from our speakers yep we have one
live sonam so sonam is asking uh sushi
is saying that i had a live tech talk
last year at pycon and i had just
rehearsed a lot and made sure 30 minutes
uh presentation on stage it somehow
shrink to
20 minutes so how to make sure that it
doesn't happen or even
use that 10 minutes so you're saying
you prepare for 30 and as you give in
the presentation it goes to 20
right it happens
so if your presentation shrinks
it's not terrible if your presentation
goes
over time that's bad and the preparation
and giving the talk out loud
is typically one way of going about it
then
it could be that people get really
nervous when they're on stage
and they speak very very fast even
though they spend a lot of time
preparing it happens it happens all the
time
is not the end of the war so don't don't
sweat it
and you're going to forget about
a lot of things that you wanted to say
and you're not going to say them
during your presentation it happens you
want to capture people attention you
want to
basically deliver some of your message
and you want people
to be kind of hungry about it you want
them to know more
so they will ask you a question and they
will come talk to you if it's an
important
an in-person presentation or they will
reach out through the chat or through
social media
so this is what happens essentially
don't sweat it is my suggestion but
if you if you prepare a lot with
experience so
over time as you get more and more
experienced these kind of things will
happen
less and less so don't worry too much
about it
so there are no more questions right now
okay let me just tell you then
what happens after your presentation and
then we can uh
either wrap it up or i'm happy to stay
on the call
so after you deliver your presentation
uh which is going to be
pre-recorded we ask you to attend
essentially some session so that the
audience
can ask you questions and for new
speakers this is often something a bit
uh
frightening because people expect
all sorts of difficult questions
uh that's usually not the case okay so
the q a session is an opportunity for
you to connect
with your audience even more you can
clarify
some concept you can sort of go back to
some point that you
discussed a bit too quickly and then you
can clarify those concepts
the type of questions that you have is
either
somebody who maybe missed a particular
detail so you have the chance to
go over it again clarify or maybe
somebody who would like to know more
about your idea
on something so the the usual questions
that you have from the pa data audience
they tend to be anyway
friendly people are there for for
learning so it's really an opportunity
to connect
with people and offer some deeper
insights so
good questions give you the opportunity
basically to
connect and to to show uh your knowledge
even even more uh people don't go uh
asking questions just to make sure that
you that you uh
feeling inadequate or just to show off
and whatnot it could happen i'm not
saying
it never happens it could happen but
typically it doesn't happen people come
for learning they sit through your
presentation for learning and then they
would like to know more
so try to look at the q a session as an
opportunity
to show your knowledge even
even better and if you don't have an
answer for a particular question if a
question feels like it's very difficult
or if it goes beyond
the topic of your presentation that's
fine
if you don't have an answer just be
honest about it
it's a bad idea if you try to make up
some kind of answer on the spot
just to look smart because people will
notice it
so just say that you don't know maybe
write a question down
so you can look it up later
if it feels like a good question offer
to follow up
if you want so you have an excuse to
chat with this person later
you don't have to do it but if it feels
like a good idea it could be an
opportunity for a nice conversation
or just simply say i don't know and we
just move on
uh on the topic of moving on um not
every question is going to be a good
question sometimes
question will sound a bit uh aggressive
or confrontational typically you know
people playing davis advocate and then
trying to look smart or something and it
could be
that people are trying to look smarter
than you or it could be
simply a genuine question that is going
to be phrased
in a way that feels a bit aggressive or
confrontational
moderators are going to filter these
questions as much as possible so there
are moderators taking care of that
if they come through if these kind of
questions come true um
don't sweat it um i know it feels like
you're
you're under attack or something but
just try to be professional
and offer a short a brief polite answer
and then we move on
and the audience will be with you okay
so whenever there is a person in the
room
trying to be smart and and being a bit
like a device advocate
everybody else will be like yeah that's
fine so the audience
will be on your side just make sure that
you um
try to to kind of uh calmly uh and
politely offering a quick question and
then we move on
the moderators should do the
moderation job if it doesn't happen
yeah the suggestion is try to be
professional people will appreciate
similarly sometimes people go off and
they start
some kind of monologue they look like
they know it all in the room
moderators should shut them down if i'm
the moderator i will
shut you down immediately if you if you
go off on a monologue i will tell you
ask your question because the q a is
about the speaker the q a is not about
the person asking the question okay if
it happens
same suggestion short polite
acknowledgement it's not it's not even
an answer that you want to that you have
to give
and we move on all in all remember the
audience will sit
through your presentation because they
want you to give a good presentation
nobody
we spend half an hour watching you
hoping that the presentation is going to
be bad
okay so the audience wants you to
succeed this is something that you
should remember
and it applies also in the in the q a
session so that's
kind of the final message that i want to
leave you with
so wrapping up two parts
two core messages focus on the audience
and take the time to prepare this is
really key everything else
is really details that will fall in
place as you go along
focus on the audience and take the time
to prepare that's my summary
that's also the end of my presentation
we are
just about at the end of the hour um i'm
happy to stay on the
call for any kind of question or comment
or chat that you might have
but i'm going to close the uh
the recording uh for now so that's the
end of the presentation
do we have any question from the
audience so there's one on the chart
marco uh
let me just close the recording
now
okay and we are stopping the recording